You may be asking yourself, or
at least, I hope you're asking yourself, hey, but what about error handling?
I didn't see a .error method on the end of that call.
And you're right.
Because unfortunately, error handling isn't actually built into JSONP.
This is a technical limitation because of what's happening behind the scenes.
But there are workarounds, like what we're doing here.
We can use setTimeout to stop the request if it runs for too long.
Before we run this AJAX request, we'll create this setTimeout function.
When we bind wikiRequestTimeout to this setTimeout function, we automatically
start a timer that will end 8000 milliseconds later, which is eight seconds.
When eight seconds are up, we'll go ahead and change the text of
the wiki element on the page to failed to get Wikipedia resources.
This is a nice fall back.
This says that if after eight seconds have gone by,
change the text on the page to this.
But of course there's a problem.
If this is all we did we would
no matter what overwrite the text inside the Wikipedia element with failed to
get Wikipedia resources after eight seconds.
In other words, even if this AJAX request came back successful,
this timeout would still occur.
These eight seconds would still pass by, and
the text of the wiki element would change to failed to get Wikipedia resources.
So, we have to add this line here, called clearTimeout, and then pass it
the variable of the timeout we created up here, which is wikiRequestTimeout.
This clear timeout will clear or stop this timeout from happening.
So inside our success method we go ahead and
pinned all the articles to the page and then say hey, stop that timeout.
We don't need that timeout anymore.
And then, it's all good.
There are a few different ways we can handle errors with JSONP requests, but
I thought this is a pretty easy way of doing it.